I've long held that the best way to sell
guns is to threaten to take away guns or
to make people think that they need guns
because it's so unsafe out there in the
world case in point we saw record gun
sales under Barack Obama constantly when
President Obama was in office we were
being scared by the NRA and by
right-wingers and by pro-gun fetishists
that the seizure of your weapons by
President Obama is imminent now of
course it never happened under Trump
we're not seeing the fear-mongering that
the president is going to take your guns
and gun sales are way down we've talked
about this the big manufacturers of
firearms revising downward budget
projections and revenue projections
another really great thing for gun sales
and for groups like the NRA are
incidents that make people feel less
safe that's the reality when there is a
mass shooting a mass school shooting a
terroristic incident people feel less
safe and thus they want to go and buy
guns and donate to the NRA and we're
seeing that there's a new report from
the FEC these numbers are stunning which
shows that donations to the NRA s
political victory fund tripled from
January to February of this year just
under a quarter of a million dollars in
January more than three-quarters of a
million dollars in February and of
course in February we had the parkland
Florida mass school shooting take place
the Center for Responsive Politics also
found that the number of people
contributing in the seven days after the
shooting increased 500% from the week
before now I'm gonna be super careful
here and Pat hold me accountable that
I'm being careful here because I don't
want to suggest that school shootings
are false flags with crisis actors in
fact I vehemently reject those
conspiracy theories what I want to point
out to you is that when the right says
shootings could be false flags as a
pretext to seize guns we need to
remember that the shootings actually
sell guns right when we see when we saw
shootings during President OPA
his presidency we would hear
fear-mongering about the seizure of guns
but no such seizure took place there
were record gun sales so if anyone
actually had the wherewithal resources
willingness and moral Vic you 'ti to
stage these shootings to trigger some
kind of action it would be the people
looking to sell the guns that would do
it because what we see happen after
these incidents is not gun seizures but
actually gun sales and I hope that I've
been clear that I'm not saying any of
these were false flags not like pointing
out that the motive that some point out
is is a is a wrong motive it's not like
you're offering a false flag of your own
and simply debunking what we hear from
Alex Jones and Infowars the rest of them
it's also notable that some of the same
people who after we have a shooting or
an incident say it's too soon to make
guns political after a shooting they
immediately started donating in record
numbers to the political arm of the
biggest lung-lung a gun lobby in the
country so they say the gun safety
advocates shouldn't make it political
but they're fine with making politically
motivated contributions to the NRA but I
actually still remain worried that this
is a losing battle for Democrats and
this is an upcoming midterm election
that should be one that Democrats can
crush Republicans on and I'm worried
that it's not going to be the case
because of the propaganda around the
left-wing gun grabbing but that's a
topic for a different day today's
episode of the show is made possible in
part by brilliant which is really an
amazing website that lets you engage in
fun and interesting problems and puzzles
to learn more about really important
stuff math science engineering the
community aspect of brilliant is great
there's over five million members there
bringing together the knowledge and
experience of their students their
educators the professionals around the
world that develop a lot of the hands-on
learning problems that you will work
through and learning with the community
makes a huge difference right when you
use brilliant you're part of that 5
million member community they share your
curiosity and love for math and science
and the community
brilliant also supports your learning
because you build the connection with
the subjects you're learning by
interacting with other people studying
the same material you can get started
right now by signing up for free at
brilliant org slash David Pakman first
200 people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
forward slash David Pakman support us by
supporting brilliant